We have three lines and we have
to figure out which of
the three are parallel.
So line A-- and it can't be
parallel on its own, it has to
be parallel to another
of the three lines.
So the equation for line
A is y is equal
to 3/4 x minus four.
Line B is 4y minus 20 is
equal to negative 3x.
And then line C is negative
3x plus 4y is equal to 40.
So to figure out if any of these
lines are parallel to
any of the other lines,
we just have to
compare their slopes.
If any two of these lines have
the same slope and they're
different lines, they have
different y-intercepts, then
they're going to be parallel.
Now line A, it's very easy
to figure out its slope.
It's already in slope-intercept
form.
This is mx plus b, the slope
is 3/4 and the y-intercept,
which isn't as relevant when
you're figuring out parallel
lines, is negative 4.
So let's see what the other
character's slopes are.
This isn't in any kind
of standard form.
It's not a standard form,
slope-intercept, or
point-slope form, but let's
see what the slope
of this line is.
So to get it into
slope-intercept form, which is
really the easiest one to pick
out the slope from, let's add
20 to both sides of
this equation.
The left-hand side, those cancel
out, that was the whole
point, you get 4y is equal
to negative 3x plus 20.
And now we can divide
everything by 4.
We are left with y is equal
to negative 3/4 x plus 5.
So in this case, y-intercept
is 5, but most importantly,
the slope is negative 3/4, so
it's different than this guy.
This is negative 3/4, this is
positive 3/4, so these two
guys definitely aren't
parallel.
Let's move on of this guy
in standard form.
So let's get the x term
on the other side.
So let's add 3x to both sides
of this equation.
Left-hand side, these
cancel out.
We're just left with 4y is equal
to 3x plus 40, or 40
plus 3x, either way.
Now we can divide both sides
by 4 you have to divide
every term by 4.
The left-hand side, you're
left with y.
The right-hand side, you
have 3/4 x plus 10.
So here, our slope is 3/4 and
our y-intercept, if we care
about it, is 10.
So this line and this line have
the exact same slope,
3/4, and they're different
lines because their
y-intercept is different.
So we know that A and C are
parallel lines and B is not
parallel to either one
of the other two.